عيد الشكر تقليد يقتصر على الولايات
المتحده وكندا وبموجب هذا التقليد يعفي
رئيس الامريكي وعندي كاين روميين في البيت
الابيض
متى بدا هذا التقليد وكيف احتفل فيه عبر
السنين في هذا التقرير
تقليد ينتظره الامريكيون كل عام انزانا
ببدء الاحتفال بالعيد المدنيه الاهم
بالنسبه لهم عيد الشكر
لهذا العام
كبيره في البيت الابيض
رومي في عيد الميلاد عام
1865 حين تم احضار الديك الى المنزل
لتناول عشاء العيد لكن
ابن الرئيس
معظم الرؤساء الذين اتوا من بعض الرئيس
لينكون لم يعفو عن الطيور المسكينه حتى
عام
1989 عندما اعفى الرئيس جورج بوش الاب عن
الديك الرومي وقال انه حر بالذهاب واصبح
من بعدها تقليدا سنويا
العفو الحريه الاحتفاظ بحياته كلها سيان
بالنسبه للديك الرومي طالب لا ينتهي به
الامر على طاوله عطله الرئيس ولكنه يبقى
دائما الطبقه الاساسيه على طاوله
الامريكيين في العيد
صباح العربيه ريتا سليمان